[Music]
Jeff Snyder here at the Kia telluride
supper suite in Park City and I am here
with the incredible cast of summertime
as well as their talented director
Carlos Lopez Estrada thanks for coming
guys thank you very much for having it
let's go let's go down the line because
everybody needs to know your names let's
start at the end
Austin Antoine my name is Tyrus winter
my name is Jason am I am I or I'm
markeesha Beiber's Carlos Lopez Estrada
and I mila kuda so guys I saw this is
opening night at Sundance and it really
I thought it blew the roof off the place
Carlos you meet you you know returning
to the festival after blind spotting
yeah critics loved it yeah the
industry's attention and then you go off
and you make this spoken word film with
a largely unknown
you know cast so why did you decide that
this was the right follow-up for you um
because these people right here are
fantastically talented they are creative
beyond belief and I felt that it was
unfair for me to be one of the smaller I
mean that's not true because a lot of
people know about you guys but I thought
it was unfair for not more people to be
aware of their poetry and the stories
that they had to tell and so what was
the genesis of the project like how did
it come about what we our producers and
myself were invited to see a a showcase
of 27 poets performing a poem each
really quickly rapid-fire one after the
other and we just walked out of that of
that event feeling so inspired
so moved so just thrilled that there was
this community of young artists that was
using spending their time to share their
stories with as many people as possible
so anyway we walked out of there we're
like how can we help help them do what
they're trying to do it could it be a
movie like Kath can we try to make their
poetry work in a movie setting and if so
what would that be like it's probably
gonna be weird but is it worth it we
talked to them they were and
there's seven months ago and here we are
and what is the name of that program get
lit words ignite okay cool
so how did you guys all get cast in this
how are you the ones chosen well for me
so get lit has like this annual classic
slam that happens like every year and
like which I believe it's like 50
schools or might be more I believe
probably 100 we compete for the title I
could get like classic slam champion and
he went out like $500 and like all this
like bragging rights so my team was the
scratch team and I was fortunate enough
to have won that competition and Carlos
was there and saw me and then I get a
call from Carlos and he's like I want
you to be in this film and I knew
nothing about film nothing about
directors so when he like called me I
was like this is Los Angeles you know
how many scammers are in Los Angeles and
I was like mmm so I like kind of
believed it but then he was like oh I
know Diana was like okay nevermind like
I digress Tyrese was one of the tires
and Jason were both that the final two
pieces of the cast and that's because we
went to that classic slam which happened
and when did it happen to in heaven in
April and we saw their performances were
just like how the we cannot make this
movie without these two people so
remember that call too
yeah I was a normal high school student
getting into trouble you know so what
kind of trouble
Polly like just talking not doing
homework you know writing on my tests
because I was bored
yeah well yeah I competed in the classic
slam as well my first year I was still
new to poetry I just got out there and
told my story you know being truthful
and honest and my English teacher mr.
Nick shoutout to you yeah she's like oh
you got an email I got an email from
Diane saying that you want to be in the
movie and I was in their second movie I
thought like a short film or something
like that I was like you know what it
won't hurt you know yeah
and like I came to the first meeting I
was like damn whoa I was still new I
didn't know anyone you know sure yeah I
was like that's right how long have you
guys been writing poetry and in
practicing spoken word I have been
writing poetry since I was nine I've
been like practicing like actively doing
spoken word since I was 15 actually like
one of the main the main character from
Carlos first movie Davi Diggs is my
first poetry teacher he came to each
other today yeah he came to my charter
school and he was you know teaching
poetry and I didn't you know I was
writing since I was nine but I didn't
know it was something that I could do
like for a living and make a career and
create opportunities for myself from it
and you know Davi Diggs he came and he
showed me that I could and so I've been
doing that since I was 15 so ten years
cuz I'm about to be 25 that's the last
time I'm gonna ever say my age after
this year I it's also coming up to about
10 years for me now I joined get lit in
high school I didn't even like poetry
that much and I was like okay I'll
audition for this thing and and it sort
of became a career for me and and like a
second family for the next almost a
decade now so I also was writing a lot
like when I was young like I can
kindergarten I was writing songs and
poems and always doing things and I
think my my freshman year I had a
high school teacher who hated poetry and
I stopped writing in the night
transferred schools all of a sudden I
had a teacher who like signed me up for
creative writing saw something in me put
my name on an open-mic list I was
nervous as heck I like threw up a bunch
before performing I had like the biggest
amount of stage fright and just over the
course of that year and over the course
of just like my entire high school
career having all these teachers support
me and people like get lit supporting me
I'd ended up doing poetry and like
falling in love with it and never I
don't think I'm ever going to stop I've
been writing stuff for quite some time I
didn't know that I was involved in
poetry when I was first writing I just
was rapping and doing like performance
stuff and I was used to let's see for
like over ten years now I was like
riding and freestyling and working in a
rap environment and then I got the
chance to step in to get lit and do
coaching for some of the youth poets and
I was like I don't know how this is
gonna work on my side and then I you
know with this used to rhyming to
impress and then stepping through a
poetry environment people were like oh
no it's expression and I would say my
verses and people would snap it's like
oh I guess I am a poet this is what
poetry is like and then from there it
was like stepping into wearing a poetry
coat and so I guess I've been claiming
the title of poet for the past three
years since being a vulva Caitlyn so to
me the only thing better than actually
being cast in a movie is telling
everyone that you've been cast in a
movie so how did your friends and family
react when you guys share the news my
brother has been like crying non-stop
every time I sent him a picture my
brother like really really loves film
and it's like he is just sending me all
these pictures of him crying he's the
one that sends me all the reviews like
he's like staying on top of it way more
than I am my parents both of them like
are just amazed and I think also some of
my friends are being really really funny
about it they're reposting absolutely
everything every time I log on Twitter
my my friend right now has a running
joke where she just keeps being like
like Milla's at Sundance and and like
completely unrelated fact to me list at
Sundance completely under every single
tweet she's just like adding that in
because she's hilarious
every review except the Hollywood
Reporter's
[Laughter]
I think like my family they were really
really supportive like like you know
nobody in my family is like ever gotten
past the front step of our neighborhood
you know what I mean and so like
everybody was like super super
supportive and my fiance was like like
he came with me to like every film just
like they like he was like there every
day for filming and so they were like
okay we're locking said like so like
everyone was super supportive it really
like made it so much more better and so
much worth it and really care when my
mom found out that we got into Sundance
she immediately tried to get a ticket
she was so excited I mean I I do yeah
well I think she's leaving today but
yeah she got a hotel room and everything
because she loves Sundance too and and I
have I acted in the past but I've never
done a feature film so for all of us it
was just the most exciting thing
possible
well my parents indicate they're
Hispanic parents so they just care about
college and there's nothing about this
where you want to go well for me my
friends were just so supportive of me
when I found out that I like got into a
film because I was trying to keep it
low-key because I was like I don't know
like when I posted on my Instagram one
day like it was a picture of me like in
a limo people were like what the [ __ ] is
going on
excuse my French and I was like what is
going on and I was just like I'm kind of
in a movie and then the dm's like
excited going up people excited like oh
my god you're amazing and I was like
thank you so much and not only just my
friends like people like Diane were just
so supportive of me and just helping me
like stay afloat like through the entire
filming process and it was so just
amazing and inspiring
um my family was like oh you're in a
movie and I'm like it like what does
this mean and I'm like I don't know but
this is cool
and then they'd be like show us pictures
we love to see so I would send little
snapshots from set and then what that's
well that's your face look I know that's
my face though that was the reaction
Austin can't tell quick sorry sure so we
had her premiere a few days ago and then
we all went out for dinner and Austin
was a little bit late because he was
doing I don't know he's doing texting
some people really hey meet us at this
bar anyway he walked into the wrong bar
and do I just see what happened welcome
to the wrong bar thinking that it was
the spot that everybody's having dinner
and I was like hey is this the spot and
then one dude immediately comes it's me
and he's like yeah you're the mama guy
mama
oh yeah that's like movies great I love
what y'all did and your character and
then we got to talking about just the
whole process of summertime it's really
gone but I thought that was real funny
that the first word that this person
said is mom now cuz I wouldn't dare ask
you to name a a ver --it but it was
there a scene that that you that you
like shootin the most or a vignette that
is an unfair question I this is gonna
sound like I'm just being untruthful
here but I think all the people that are
here gave know that it's not true and
it's not right because the people that
are not here also gave beautiful
beautiful performances I don't know I
look Mila wrote two poems for the movie
and they're both absolutely stunning she
wrote one she wrote one for the movie
and she wrote one in post-production
that we ended up it ended up becoming
like the overture for the movie she also
was a poetry supervisor so she helped
every single person in the movie Brad is
a cool title not a lot of movies have a
poetry super it's we're very happy
shooting rikishi scene was one of the
most transformative experiences of my
life I will never forget that day I will
never forget you losing your nail right
before we were supposed to shoot and
everyone and everyone in the crew at
like 2:00 a.m. just looking around the
grass from our quiches now
Maya I'm honestly a big fan of I've seen
her perform so many times and I was kind
of starstruck to know that she was
working with us Tyrus and Jason also we
found them at the classic poetry slam
and we were just like geez whatever
movie cannot exist without these two
faces and Austin is also a master of
disaster every one of his scenes people
loved him and and Bryce Anubis and rah
and that was all them it was it was the
biggest surprise their storyline didn't
exist we met them they started riffing
off of each other we're like oh man you
guys are just like make some room glue
yeah I love what you did with the fast
food scene just with all the commotion
everybody yelling and everything yes but
but you know I I have to say and I think
Perry would agree mark marques or you
were incredible and that that scene was
heartbreaking and it moved me to tears
so can you just talk about how personal
that was for you cuz it felt like
something that you'd lived well yeah
it's a real-life experience when I was
15 that actually happened to me
some you know guy you know high school
boy he knows a jerk you know I mean and
what actually wound up happening is I
didn't write the poem until I was 17
because I I started working with get lit
and like I was like going to New York
and I was doing all this stuff and like
I had posted something about like man I
wish I wasn't single and I had someone
to share this with or something like
that and like the same guy who kind of
like just like ripped my whole life
apart at fifteen was like oh you're so
beautiful and like you just have to find
someone who looks at you through the
eyes that I have and I'm like wait what
and like I'm like on the bus and I'm
thinking and I'm like I'm in my head and
I wrote the poem in my head and I got
home and I was like mom listen to this
and I said it to her and she like forced
me to sit at the computer and write it
down and so like that's where the poem
came from cuz I was like like like you
literally like had me in the hospital
for like months like you know what I
mean like depressed and just like
beating myself up and then like two
years later I got me New York and you're
like you're beautiful and I'm like I'll
kick you in the face like and so like
but it was really therapeutic because I
never got the opportunity to
share that piece or even confront him in
that in real life and like you know
Cyrus actually resembles him kind of and
so like it was like actually like
therapy I'm like it felt like I was back
in that moment and I got to say all the
things that like he took my voice away
in that moment and I was finally getting
a chance to get it back so it was it was
really therapeutic I actually had to
tell Tyrus like stop looking at me like
that Carlos what are your goals in terms
of distribution for this film is this
something that you see going to theaters
you think to streaming would be a
smarter play for it I honestly have no
idea I I feel like the best the best
outcome is the one where the greatest
amount of people are able to learn about
these poets and the things that they
have to say ah I mean I love going to
the theater so I would love for it to
have some form of theatrical release
also because I think that this is an
experience that you probably got a lot
more out of if you see it with a group
of people have you seen within a
community different people connect to
different poems for different reasons
the arguments that happen after movie
after the movies done people who like
your people who didn't like it I
connected to that poem but not to this
one it just inspires I think such a
healthy conversation so I I definitely
hope that it ends up in theaters
somewhere at some point but also I know
that most of us consume a lot of our
video stuff Moberly so I don't know if
if maybe it's also best to end up in
some kind of streaming place that allows
people to just see it and share it
easily I do think that people my age
people their age are really gonna get a
lot out of these stories so I don't know
I hope we can get hope we can get all of
it okay alright guys thank you so much
to the Kia Telluride supper suite for
hosting us the fabulous cast and
director of summertime thank you